hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the bears black heart now
imagine that you're a bear trying to
survive in the winter it's gonna be a
harsh one and you need to get as much
food as possible in your little tum tum
or else you're gonna turn ravenous and
start to make choices you don't want to
make so there's a procedurally generated
game that supposedly Oh
WASD to walk spacebar to interact escape
to pause Mouse is like dialogue oh okay
so anyway you're a bear and you have a
cuddly little heart but you got to make
sure that you survive okay hello hello
hello welcome to fuzzy Hollow hello
there you look like another one of those
insomniac bears been drinking too much
coffee eh not to worry we'll help you
get through the winter keep your belly
full and your heart clear and be nice
and you'll make it through you're
absolutely nuts I'm out of here
okie dokie you're on your own Oh
something tells me that probably wasn't
the best choice okay okay so numb okay
good all right good great great good I
ate a squirrel I probably shouldn't do
that as king of the squirrels oh good
great good hate that okay YUM okay well
this ain't so bad is that a picnic
basket
um okay hey this doesn't seem bad at all
I mean where's the challenge am I gonna
die here what's gonna happen what's the
worst gonna happen nom okay
yay wandering new in a part of the
forest okay
nom nom I'm also wondering why am i why
am i a mason jar
esque beer why isn't where's my bear
body separated by a giant jar of fluid
with a floating heart that doesn't seem
to actually be doing anything Oh what
I'm into my heart wait what the hell
happened to my heart what oh oh I
shouldn't be eating squirrels oh I'm an
Oh Oh No
I've been goofing this whole time Oh No
okay well I thought that it would be
nicely I
but I thought Bears were supposed to eat
squirrels oh I've done that everybody
I've done horribly bad I'm a good bear
of a very good bear as far as I know the
fact I think I think I don't need to eat
anything I'm pretty sure that I've got
absolutely everything that I need my
stomach has been full this entire time I
mean it's not like I can pack on fat
I've just gotta jump holy
what the are you gobble the dots
gobble the ghosts but it's fruit I love
the most your heart is too dark to do
this oh my heart is too dark to do this
one gobble the gobbler the curse has
been passed turns out if you eat a dot
gobbler you become a dot gobbler Plus
Rudy ate some food plus corruption plus
gob learn you're a Danka what does that
mean what I'm done oh no oh no oh no
that's annoying as go oh it's
making my heart black oh no oh no oh no
I don't think there's any other food
besides just dots oh no oh no what am I
done
hello hi how are you you here chopping
and come across a woodcutter he's
absorbed in his work and doesn't see you
your heart is too tired to do this
alright you know what I'll just commit
to the darkness I'm gonna eat the
woodcutter he's lean and tasty this is
probably the best human you've ever
tasted even yummier than that tender
lost brownie who wandered the woods
playing pokemons go Oh No plus fresh
food fills you up more well that's handy
unfortunately I'm the gobbler that is no
good ah my heart is almost completely
black oh no it is not good Oh what's
gonna happen when it turns black no oh
boy I wish out stop oh hi
please eat me please eat me take the
curse I can't stand it
you're accosted when a forest ranger
jumps out from behind a tree I know you
see says you stole that picnic basket
last month well Tammy you attack and eat
the Ranger but not before he calls for
help he spent a horrible week on the run
with no food from his workmates orly
escaping by jumping off a waterfall Oh
No well I'm an that's not good
run it out of food run it out of will to
live
somebody please eat me
Oh No oh hi oh hello you hear an
annoying grunt and find an angry little
guy in a wheelchair there's a bunch of
balloons next to him I don't want to fly
with balloons he screams let the let the
balloons go eat the little guy let the
balloons go
the balloons float right off into the
engine of the passing airplane which
causes it to crash into the forest
killing many people at animals what what
what
excuse me less food found in the world
how in the did that happen oh hello
hi how are you doing hello Marian and
Frank you look strange today would you
like to come into my box of tea the
freaky little doll beckons you over to a
small yellow box yeah maybe it's maybe
it's time to do this you see the
mummified remains of a man and woman
there seems to be no marks on their legs
you feel a pain in your foot intensive
ball biting it you smash his head and
run for it you don't as you move slower
oh great oh one of my ducks
but if this I wanna be a good bear I
just want to be a good bear oh I want to
be a good bear
I have a good bear I'm a good noodle I'm
a good noodle please just let me die my
cold and alone with my waka walkers in
this corner please just end my suffering
please
oh you starved you lasted six weeks to
her slow ravenous fresh famine and gob
lured god dammit of course I made the
worst possible decision eating the
gobbler was I filled with piss
where is it yellow oh okay let me try
that again I'm gonna try one more time
this time I'm gonna be good I'm gonna be
real good so I'm gonna talk to you sure
thing
and remember spring is only 15 short
weeks away you can speed things up by
talking to people you find in
investigating things okay can do oh my
god there's no Wacka Wacka x' that is so
wonderful
oh god it's you hi gobble gobble gobble
madhan's gobble gobble gobble gobble my
dots
okay I'm gonna feed him as Dutt's he
gobbles your face in his frenzy dot
gobbling gobbler calm your heart got a
little darker and I have gobbler vision
well that's not good at all is there any
what does gobbler vision mean what does
that mean and why did my heart get
darker what did I do to you I'm not
gonna eat those picnic baskets cuz they
mean bad stuff for me but I'm gonna eat
at this Apple okay I don't know what
gobbler vision meant but uh apparently
I'm okay everything seems to be going
100% smoothly
oh hello you're new hi the poor bunny
needs help fixing her basket she can't
collect any berries for her babies fix
the basket with some fluff from your
bellybutton offered to buy her new one
eat the basket bite her face I'm gonna
fix a basket with a fluff from a
bellybutton
that's just where she bases you cheap
bass
is you why won't she miss me why I'm
trying to help yeah I guess that was
weird I thought it oh my god you've got
to be kidding me
you are with me you're
kidding me
Oh No well this ain't good
there's gonna be another 60 seconds type
situation where I'm never gonna be able
to survive this because it's all
randomly generated I mean it
could be good or bad I suppose I mean
maybe eating the lumberjack was actually
the best bet oh man I don't want to eat
the bunny because if family I don't work
here what do I care it's a cartoon bunny
in a video game I know I care about his
family but I do this is a badge the
little baby bunnies all by themselves
I couldn't eat their mama she'd be dead
oh hello gobbler why are you back why
are you back gobble the dots gobble the
ghosts but it's fruit I love the most
all right you know what I'm gonna gobble
the fruit uh mango you won't be able to
sleep you have flatulence you fart I
fart in the dark of a dark farter I mark
the dark farter good for me huh
everybody's happy about that okay
that's nice that's lovely I'm I'm really
glad that's happening to me I'm glad
okay that's good okay great all right I
gotta admit though this is actually kind
of fun it's not what I expected it it's
not what I expected out of the game but
you know I gotta say it's got some charm
to it I like the randomly generated so
you hear sobbing and you find a
woodcutter he explains that he was
swinging his axe in the head flew off
into a stream he seems very upset help
him find the axe head you whistle in
your little pal freed montt fish pops up
from the water before happily retrieving
it for you the woodcutter then chops
your arm off in a fit of glee what a
corny world what what what I should have
eaten that that is a weird thing
for me to shout I take back that
statement I take it back
alright the farts aren't helping my case
in any in any aspect here I should have
eaten that lumberjack all right
well okay Oh
Doh I'm not gonna make this one I don't
want this I don't want anything I've
only got one arm how am I gonna be able
to make it through this I'm not the
answer is no oh no you think that you
think that the effects of a mango
wouldn't last this long
okay I don't want to fly with balloons
fly yourself with balloons aren't I'm
gonna fly you launch yourself in the air
with balloons but are too heavy and you
crash land into a tree hurting your leg
great awesome wonderful okay yeah that's
good
all right you know what it's fine she's
gonna carry on I've only getting
corruption just because these
seem to be with me not because
I'm doing anything wrong I wonder if
there's any positive way to get out of
those things I mean the only positive
thing that happened was when I ate the
Oh what are you mushroom you hear
squeaking and look down to see a
mushroom and with a face oh there my man
it says you can fetch me ten apples from
the woods I'm gonna eat the mushrooms
for the psychedelic effect you feel
trippy all trees are mushrooms I don't
oh no oh no I see the ghost of a thing
that I ate right in front of me oh stop
farting you stop stop it was just one
mango man it was just one mango okay
yeah I mean it's so funny because the
game is so cute see and everything but
as hard it's horrible it's it's really a
dire situation here I mean I gotta make
it to 15 weeks just doesn't seem too
terribly bad but along the way I got to
do some horrible things to some horrible
people stop farting please I'm trying to
make a profound statement about them the
morality of what I'm doing here for
survival for myself and how many people
did it how many people that I'm killing
on long way if you could stop fighting
I'm trying to make a profound saving
literally you know you could Kasabian's
figuratively oh hello alright
okay climb into I'm gonna climb into
this box climbing in you sit next to the
mummified remains of a man and a woman
we're gonna fatten up you up says the
doll it shoves apples into your mouth
you fight it off and make a break for it
as you run away freaky piano music
begins to play oh ow now they're gonna
be freaky pianos oh oh no okay that's
not so bad
that's fine I thought that was gonna be
freakin piano music accompanying me for
this whole game Bailey it's alright oh
hello again
alright you know what I'm going to do it
you know what to do wait you hear uh
there's a guy talking about me he
says you know what to do you know what
to do do you know what to do do what you
know what to do you know what to do when
you do it when it's done you not know
not what no you see I see more bad
choices
they've all been bad choices all of them
all of my choices have been bad plus I'm
very corrupt in my heart stop farting oh
hello again hello welcome back
sounds of anger attract you to a hiker
she seems very frustrated howdy there
mr. bear she says would you give me a
hand putting up my tent I just can't
seem to get it right how about I refused
to help as you walk away she starts to
cry her sadness seems to split the sky
and you spend a cold wet lonely night
under a bush Minji the choices you make
make you more worse oh well that's I am
my heart is black great and I'm starving
I haven't found enough food I'm gonna
have to just eat square rolls stop
please please just stop oh hello
rawr a monster jumps out a little ball
of poo escape from your bum with the
fright eat the monster the monster is
pregnant
and now you have 12 little monster of
your own square Ian's on your body not
good you fart I guess I fart more now do
I fart twice his bunch and why I don't
want to fern stop
oh god it's twice as much isn't it of
course I get another farting bad thing
of course stop farting don't hello oh
you meet a wonderful singing ghost he
wants to perform to you well too bad I
can only eat you you rebel rebel you but
eh you can't eat ghosts empty cows
ravenous you get hungry faster well damn
it I am NOT gonna make it am i I see
something over there
oh it's the doll again knock knock up
and wide see what's on the other side
knock knock even more to come even more
come with me through the magic door this
creepy little thing wants you to follow
it front of the doors behind it eat the
doll you shove the wooden doll in your
mouth the wooden head splits spilling
gears and cogs into your belly you feel
your stomach start to eat god damn it I
fart even more why gotta keep getting
every single one I've gotten has made me
fart fine
I'm almost done might as well go
through this try to get to the end of it
can I eat a rock plate anything just a
few more and I'm done I guess I just it
spring comes in two more weeks two more
weeks I got this oh stop farting stop
stop parting no time to fart unless is
propelling me further into the fourth
don't fart God why did I get maced in
the eyes like the second week in hello
you hear someone blowing whistle and
come running to find a forest ranger
arresting another air heat the both you
barrel into both of them and knock him
out before they can wake up you hog time
and even bit by bit over the course of
the next week you get a stomach ache I
fart even more god dammit it must
be impossible to fire
like to not fart through this this
is like a perpetual fart train Jesus did
not stop farting from start to finish I
mean I guess that's life anyway it's a
non-stop fart fest as long as you go I
mean maybe that's supposed to be the
deep reality that we all get from this
game is that you you just understand
that life is just full of farts and
there's nothing that you can do to stop
it
last person yes hello you're accosted
when a forest ranger jumps out from I
eat him you're tagging eat the Ranger
but not before he calls for help bla bla
bla bla okay is it done
god damn it why am I still going do I
gotta finish this week to stop farting
stop farting stop stop oh man I gotta
eat who's gonna be the last week there's
gonna be a dire one isn't it hello
let's see wah bah blah blah blah blah
eat him he's lean and tasty yes best
ever
yes am I done woo
yeah I lasted fifteen weeks i won whose
flatulence times four oh boy okay so
anyway that is the Bears black heart not
a bad ending to this this is kind of an
interesting game I don't know if it's
possible to get through the whole game
with your heart not being black but I'm
pretty sure that's all a design of the
game considering the game is called the
Bears black heart but I did it so if you
want to try for yourself I'll put a link
to the game in the description below
thank you everybody so much for watching
and let me know what you think down the
comments below do you think farts are
funny ha ha ha maybe I'm not judging you
you write me you tell me so either way
thank you so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
[Music]